وزير الدفاع التركيه خلصي اكارون رئيس
المخابرات هاكان في دان التقيا في موسكو
في وزير الدفاع السوري علي محمود عباس
ورئيس المخابرات علي مملوك بحضور وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويكو وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اشارت في بيان الى ان هذا
الاجتماع تطرق الى سبل الازمه السوريه
ومشكله اللاجئين والجهود المشتركه لمحاربه
الجماعات المتطرفه في سوريا وهو ما ورد في
بيان اخر صدر عن وزاره الدفاع التركيه
نقلته وكاله الانباء السوريه سانا وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ذكرت في بيانها ايضا ان
الفراقاء شددوا على الطبيعه البنا اهل
الحوار بالشكل الذي عقيد فيه وضروره
مواصلاته بغيه ارسال استقرار في سوريا
ياتي هذا اللقاء بين اكره عباس في وقت
يهدد فيه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
منذ اسابيع بشنه هجوم العسكري في شمال
سوريا ضد مجموعات كرديه وكان اكار اشار
الاسبوع الماضي الى انقره تتواصل مع موسكو
بشان فتح المجال الجوي السوري امام
المقاتلات التركيه اردوغان كان اعلن في
وقت سابق من هذا الشهر انه اقترح على
نظيره الروسيب الذي مير بوتين تشكيل اليه
ثلاثيه مع روسيا وسوريا لتسريع
الدبلوماسيه بين انقره ودمشق كما عبر عن
رغبته في لقاء الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد